las informaciones que llegan de donets
la capital de los territorios
separatistas junto al ones son
preocupantes durante la noche se han
escuchado varias explosiones mientras
tanto rusia ha añadido a sus últimas
medidas de presión que continuará con
sus maniobras en territorio bielorruso
muy cerca de la frontera de ucrania
demasiado cerca desde el punto de vista
de que el presidente vladimir putin
mantendrá hoy una conversación
telefónica con el presidente francés
emmanuel macrón todos muy pendientes de
si pudiese lograrse algún avance en a
partir de esa charla entre los dos jefes
de estado mientras tanto en kiev sigue
creciendo la preocupación algunas
embajadas más se han han retirado sus
oficinas o bien del país o bien se las
han llevado hacia el oeste ha hecho lo
mismo también la delegación de la otan y
desde los territorios que limitan con
los separatistas
se toman muchísimas precauciones y hoy
ha habido un anuncio de que se cierra
uno de los pasos que comunican con los
territorios separatistas porque en los
últimos días se han producido una gran
cantidad de ataques